[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture le point
sur l'actualité culturelle des yvelines
avec aujourd'hui la compagnie art
d'intro présente son premier film au
nikon film festival intitulé un air de
piano
le court métrage est présenté au vote
des internautes jusqu'au 11 avril
johanna soudry blasco directrice
artistique de la compagnie nous en
parlera au cours de cette émission
en attendant le retour de son public et
la graineterie située à houilles hommes
à monter l'exposition collective les
lieux du lisible une installation pour
faire découvrir des lieux inaccessibles
au grand public
au programme peinture photographie ou
encore culture nous l'avons découverte
en avant-première
et puis la fête du conte est lancé
jusqu'au 13 mars
c'est une programmation 100% en ligne
qui vous attend une action proposé par
le réseau des médiathèques ou saint
quentin en yvelines
nous vous ferons découvrir le programme
jusqu'au 13 mars la fête du conte
souffle à saint-quentin-en-yvelines ses
20 bougies cette année c'est forcément
une programmation 100% en ligne qui vous
attend animations lectures de contes
spectacles jeux sont proposés sur le
site du réseau des médiathèques
écoutez à ce sujet le vice président en
charge de la culture de l'agglomération
laura plusieurs événements avec dans un
premier temps appel à l'écriture qui
était organisé par là pour accueillir
les contes écrits par les saint
quentinois
et puis il 8 au 10 mars au 8 avril le
conteur stéphane des feux qui est un
conteur professionnel racontera les
continueront plus le plus et voilà parmi
tous ceux qu'il aura reçues donc tout ça
est bien sûr disponible en ligne sur le
portail culture en ligne du portail de
50 ans et à partir du 27 février
dura deux veillées de contes pour
frissonner de plaisir à l'occasion des
soirées femme seule chair de poule que
les habitués connaissent bien encore de
la saga serpent rêve qui propose trois
épisodes pour savoir tout sur l'origine
béral je reçois à présent un johanna
soudry blasco bonsoir bonsoir fait lien
vous êtes la directrice artistique de la
compagnie yvelinoise art d'impro une
compagnie qui produit le court métrage
un air de piano dont on va voir quelques
images rapidement regarder
alors ce court métrage est en
compétition au nikon film festival
c'est le thème du festival cette année
le jeu j e u qui vous a donné envie de
vous lancer dans ce projet pas vraiment
ses boutons la conjoncture en fait comme
à la base on fait beaucoup de théâtre et
que vous savez à cause de la crise
sanitaire un peu plus du tout joué c'est
horrible on a essayé de en fait de se
réinventer et d'adapter ce qu'on faisait
sur scène mais en vidéo
alors les nikon festival c'est vraiment
un festival que tout le monde connaît un
peu dans le milieu des comédiens des
vidéastes
donc c'est quelque chose on a toujours
un peu dans le coin de sa tête en se
disant membre a sûrement un jour n'y
participera est donc lancée du baas et
c'est vraiment l'occasion rêvée on va y
aller et le thème bas nous comme on fait
du tad d'impro on est très habitué à
écrire à partir des suggestions du
public en tout cas des suggestions
extérieur donc la deuxième c'était un
jeu et on s'est dit bon bah écrivons là
dessus par rapport à ce qu'on sait faire
et on a donc écrit ce petit court
métrage qui est vraiment court 2 minutes
20 sur le réalisme magique qui et c'est
ce que vous allez me pose des questions
on va en parler car j'ai bon parce que
pour participer du coup il a fallu donc
respecté plusieurs contraintes
le format d'eau 2 minutes 20 vous l'avez
dit et puis vous avez aussi voulu rendre
un hommage à l'auteur colombien
colombien gabriel garcia marquez et du
coup à son réalisme magique et c'est ça
exactement c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui est propre à la culture colombienne
ou dans la troupe la compagnie taton
mais pas mal dix panneaux c'est vraiment
une volonté artistique qu'on a donc on a
des colombiens on a aussi des espagnols
on a un peu de tout et ce réalisme
magique sa ferme en partie de leur
culture c'est quelque chose qui
ressemble un peu à nos comptes à nous où
on va expliquer des choses de la vie
plutôt grave ou pas agréable et là bas
on va les expliquer de façon très
poétique avec la nature qui est vraiment
un briquet et donc on s'est dit qu'on ne
sait quelque chose qu'on adore faire
jouer sur scène à la manière de garcia
marquez donc on s'est dit ah ben là
c'est l'occasion rêvée dans ce court
métrage pour justement mettre tout tout
tout est thématique du réalisme magique
par exemple concrètement il peut se
remettre à pleuvoir sur une ville
pendant 45 ans c'est normal c'est voilà
c'est dit
réalisme magique donc c'était un peu
magique mais on estime que c'est normal
et donc s'il pleut pendant 45 ans à la
ville le village va être engloutis donc
c'est un petit peu voilà tous tous ses
ressorts là c'est très métaphorique
aussi c'est très poétique et et donc on
a essayé de mettre tout ça là dedans
dans ces deux minutes pour essayer de
partager ce qu'on aimait avec les gens
en fait le court métrage est dans lequel
vous jouez d'ailleurs est signée jeunes
dada il est question d'un homme sur le
front de la guerre et c'est la musique
quelques notes qui vont le relier à sa
famille ce que vous pouvez peut-être
nous parler de cette histoire
oui en fait on aime bien quand on écrit
donné plusieurs lectures en fait
plusieurs niveaux de lecture il ya le
premier niveau de lecture on prend
vraiment au premier degré tout ce qu'on
voit tout ce qui se passe et après il ya
toutes les interprétations qu'on peut en
faire
là l'idée c'est que bas nous on est
privé de musique on est privée d'art
jeudi nous les artistes mais aussi le
spectateur on est privé de ce lien qui
fait aussi qu'on est humain on a encore
besoin de se voir on a besoin d'imaginer
un besoin de s'évader et là c'est plus
possible et c'est un peu ce que vit ce
jeune gars bloquer le personnage
principal il joue quand ils jouent va y
vit ils revivent avec les siens il avec
les gens qu'il aime et quand il part à
la guerre ben il est privé parce colonel
il est privé de ce qui fait sa vie de ce
qui fait son quotidien
et là il va dans les moments très très
difficiles pouvoir s'échapper et revivre
grâce à l'art grâce à la musique
et j'imagine qu'il ya aussi un autre
message donc dans ce court métrage
montré que du coup la musique aussi
c'est quelque chose d'essentiel et
surtout en ce moment exactement mais
c'est exactement ça on a besoin de l'art
pour vivre on a besoin de ce qu'on aime
près de nous et en fait tout ça le
réalisme magique vous a permis aussi
d'exprimer tous à toutes les souffrances
qu'on connaissait en ce moment c'est
vraiment difficile pour tourner à tous
les niveaux on essaie d'être des
solutions et on essaie de pouvoir
vivre en fait au maximum et le plus
possible étant donné qu'on peut plus du
tout ni jouer ni travailler en fait
d'ailleurs j'ai dit jouer qui était le
thème d'une icône festive à un jeu qu'on
peut plus faire tout ça donc on essaie
bas comme on peut d'avoir accès à cette
magie de l'art cette magie de l'écriture
cette magie de l'image la magie de la
musique du film de l'improvisation du
théâtre du jeu de tout ça quoi et pour
découvrir un peu plus votre compagnie
donc rendez vous sur votre site internet
créé à low cost point com et puis ce
court métrage est donc visible aussi sur
le site du nikon festival un air de
piano
n'oubliez pas donc de voter pour eux
vous avez plus de voir ça nous suffit de
voir fonctionner content de partager ça
avec vous et bien on vous avez jusqu'au
11 avril en tout cas pour le faire
gagner et mettre en valeur le travail
notamment du réalisateur john nada
merci à houilles le centre d'art à la
graineterie ne fait pas exception et
garde ses portes closes depuis le 30
octobre
initialement prévue fin janvier
l'exposition les lieux du visible ne
peut donc pas se dévoiler au grand
public mais les artistes sont déjà prêts
découverte en avant-première dans ce
reportage
regardez les lieux du visible une
exposition montée malgré la crise
sanitaire pour maintenir l'activité
en attendant le retour du public
l'exposition est accessible aux
professionnels et à destination des
scolaires comme tous les lieux culturels
on peut ouvrir uniquement sur rendez
vous donc on reçoit
on reçoit des petits groupes de
professionnels dans l'exposition assez
régulièrement une exposition collective
qui réunit quatre artistes au programme
peinture photographie sculpture et
dessin objectif de l'exposition faire
découvrir des lieux peu visibles voire
inaccessibles au grand public les fonds
sous-marins avec nicolas floch qui a un
parcours assez extraordinaire artiste
bien sûr mais aussi marin et plongeurs
de formation renault patar lui s'est
beaucoup intéressé ces dernières années
à l'univers carcéral
agnès geoffrey elle prend souvent comme
point de départ dans son travail
les archives et timothée schelstraete
donc l'artiste qui présente les
peintures dans l'espace d'exposition qui
lui en fait à une pratique de flâneurs
qui
parcourent la ville prend des
photographies et révèle des détails
auxquels on ne prête généralement pas
d'attention la graineterie le centre
d'art de la ville de houilles
le lieu était à l'origine une ferme
devenue une graineterie dans les années
d'où son nom la ville a souhaité
conserver son caractère patrimonial
aussi la cour centrale c'est le lieu
d'exposition pour le centre d'art et
c'est le lieu autour duquel tout
s'articule en fait tous les lieux de
culture on a tenu à conserver le
caractère rural et patrimoniale de ce
lieu d'où l'ouverture du silo à grains
les mangeoires dans ce qui s'appelle
encore l'écurie la porte de faire la
vitrine de l'ancienne boutique
l'exposition les lieux du visible devait
se terminer le 6 mars pour permettre au
public de voir le projet l'installation
est prolongée jusqu'au 22 mai le sixième
album de monsieur gontran intitulé 76 à
la noire vient de sortir il ya quelques
semaines un album qui s'inscrit dans la
tradition de la chanson française astrid
bergès bonsoir soir 76 à la noire est
composé de 18 chansons et une reprise
oui c'est un album piano voix dans une
ambiance intimiste ce sont des chansons
assez douces et un peu mélancolique
on écoute un extrait du titre combien de
gens
tandis que je les yeux
de mensonges sur elle
76 à la noire est un album avec
différentes thématiques sassari la vie
l'amour
ce sont des thématiques assez
nostalgique quelqu'un qu'il retrouve la
maison où il avait vécu 20 ans avant et
il rentre dedans il rencontre les gens
qui sont il ya une chanson qui parle de
de l'affection d'une vieille personne
pour son chien
donc voilà c'est des cd des univers qui
parle de la vie du temps qui passe ils
resteront peut-on trouver cet album
alors l'album est disponible sur toutes
les plateformes de téléchargement légal
mais il fait aussi l'objet d'une édition
limitée double vinyle le côté vinyle
d'avoir d'avoir un objet d'avoir une
pochette d'avoir un livre est là c'est
un double album s'il ya dix-huit
chansons plus une reprise c'est un
double album il ya livré 16 pages avec
toutes les paroles des chansons des
photos levine savoir qu'on écoute de la
musique on n'entend pas aujourd'hui la
musique est partout je dirais c'est bien
souvent un bruit de fond à bruit de fond
dans sa voiture bruit de fond dans un
restaurant où ils font dans un magasin
c'est très agréable mais ça reste un
bruit de fond tandis qu'un vinyle
a priori c'est plutôt un objet qui est
fait pour écouter de la musique ça va
être que l'activité en tant que tel
alors les dix-huit chansons étaient déjà
écrites avant le confinement une seule a
été composé pendant elle s'appelle 20
ans en 2020 le clip a été tourné au
printemps dernier écoutez monsieur
gontran suivi d'un extrait du clip
regardez on se projette en 2100 on va
dire et c'est un c'est un petit garçon
qui demande à son grand père un grand
père comment cet état j en 2020 comment
sais tu es à ton époque comment c'était
voilà quand quand tu as vécu tout ça
jeunes donc c'est un petit peu langue l
approche de cette de cette chanson
terré d'épidémie
weston
du sud
ressources
[Musique]
et un projet d'album de reprise guitare
voix avec ses filles sortira courant de
cette année eh bien merci astrid pour
toutes ces précisions
c'est la fin de ce numéro du 7-8 culture
n'oubliez pas d'aller consulter nos
replay sur le site internet on se
retrouve bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]